bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur lcp au sommaire de ça vous regarde
ce soir une émission 100% législatives à
48 heures du second tour ont fait le
bilan de cette campagne avec nos invités
beaucoup de questions ce soir emmanuel
macron aura-t-il une majorité absolue à
l'assemblée sa stratégie d'entre deux
tours et est elle la bonne partir loin
de la france pendant plusieurs jours et
appelé à un sursaut républicain pour
mobiliser les antilles mélenchon jean
luc mélenchon justement son objectif à
lui c'est de mobiliser les jeunes est de
rassembler les antilles matheron mais
peut-il vraiment rêver d'une victoire
dimanche soir quant aux républicains ils
veulent convaincre que le vrai vote
utile 7e avec cette idée d'incarner une
opposition déterminée mais utile qu'ils
pourraient voter au cas par cas
certaines réformes mais n'est ce pas là
un jeu dangereux pour la droite enfin le
rassemblement national va-t-il percer le
plafond de verre c'est la seule force
politique qui a progressé au 1er tour
par rapport à à 2017 mais il lui faut
maintenant transformer l'essai avec un
mode de scrutin qui ne lui est pas
favorable voilà pour le sommaire c'est
parti pour une heure d'infos et des
analyses
[Musique]
et pour faire le bilan de cette campagne
des législatives nous accueillons agathe
l'ambré bonsoir vous êtes journaliste
service politique de bfm échos trice de
cet ouvrage l'étrange victoire macron de
l'histoire secrète que vous avez co
écrit avec louis aux haltères et qui
vient de paraître aux éditions de
l'observatoire on parlera de cette
étrange campagne en l'occurrence des
législatives laurent de boissieu bonsoir
journaliste au service politique de la
croix arnaud benedetti bonsoir vous êtes
politologue professeur associé à la
sorbonne et rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire
et puis dans quelques instants on
accueillera catherine tricot qui est la
directrice de la revue regards il s'en
est passé des choses pendant cet entre
deux tours d'une semaine que faut-il en
retenir on voit cela avec stéphane
blakowski
bonsoir stéphanois je vais vous dire
bonsoir ça tombe bien soir clément ça va
bonsoir à tous d'ailleurs à tout alors
stéphane si j'ai bien compris basses ces
législatives à son plein d'incertitudes
en tout cas c'est si j'ai bien compris
il ya quand même plus de suspense pour
ses législatives qui y en avait pour le
second tour de la présidentielle là
franchement on l'a avec quasiment la
certitude que c'était macron qui
l'emporterait cette fois ci il n'y a pas
de certitude regarder ce que dit ipsos
alors j'ai choisi pso ce parce que c'est
notre partenaire évidemment mais aussi
parce que c'est le meilleur vu que c'est
eux qui était le plus proche des bons
résultats au premier tour lorsqu'ils
nous disent ipsos que la majorité
pourrait être un frein pour que le
combat qu'on pourra voir entre 265 et
305 sièges donc là on est vraiment très
à travailler bien avancé ça veut dire
quoi sa venue d'ipsos ça veut dire que
ces élections ça peut être aussi bien un
terrible échec pour macron que un succès
flamboyant puisque à 265 on est vraiment
très largement loin de la majorité
absolue de 189 sièges donc là c'est
vraiment le terrible échec mais 305
c'est le succès foudroyant parce que là
il ya une vraie marge pour gouverner les
mains libres donc incertitude totale
alors la vérité ou
alors moi basiquement je dis la vérité
entre les deux souvent donc j'ai fait la
moyenne
les séances pour 465 divisé par deux ça
nous ferait dans une estimation moyenne
de 280 sièges de 185 sièges alors c'est
ballot à 3 sièges près de la majorité
absolue donc il ya vraiment un risque de
ne pas l'obtenir donc il faut se lancer
dans cette campagne à fond alors la
stratégie macro c'était un peu de jouer
sur l'effet drapeau aller à kiev ap que
c'était la guerre en europe et donc
donner envie aux français de se
rassembler autour de leur président mais
ce matin elle a été sur rtl en même pas
dans le studio où elle est en campagne à
vire elisabeth bornes elisabeth bornes
elle bat on sentait que c'était vraiment
la dernière interview et dans ces cas là
plutôt que de défendre son programme
c'est souvent plus simple de dézinguer
programme de l'adversaire il ya deux
projets qui sont très différents du
nôtre je vous dis c'est protéger les
français créer des emplois baisser les
impôts et puis de l'autre côté on a un
projet qui sait détaxation des impôts
massifs
c'est aussi une remise en cause de nos
alliances internationales dans un
contexte qui est où il ya beaucoup
d'instabilité c'est un projet dangereux
pour notre économie et donc c'est un
projet qu'il faut absolument éviter
et dieu côté danube comment est-ce qu'on
aborde cette fin de campagne eh ben on
maintient les sports on change pas
l'oeil le coup de génie de mélenchon
cette campagne c'est l'idée de élisez
moi premier ministre ç'a permis de
mobiliser son camp de donner un but à
tous ses partisans le faire élire à
matignon donc là on se dit que selon ce
sondage c'est impossible mais non c'est
pas impossible certainement pas vous
savez ce qu'il fera
lundi jean luc mélenchon on écoute vous
serez ou lundi matin eh bien je serai
chez moi voulez vous que je sois ma
chère et tendre et le coup de téléphone
du président de la république pour moins
demandé de former le gouvernement voilà
cette tactique a marché on la maintient
jusqu'au bout on a compris que le
principal problème pour l'année pèse
s'étaient mobilisés son électorat
l'autre jour soit france inter mélenchon
disait si les quartiers populaires et
les jeunes se mobilisent on sera élu
sinon on sera battue alors comment faire
pour mobiliser les jeunes en sept
derniers jours de campagne
pourquoi pas leur promettre par exemple
un chèque de 1000 euros s'ils votent
pour mélenchon ça ça peut être efficace
et même un chèque de 1000 euros tous les
mois explication de la drica tenace il
ya le croit 70% j'ai dit tout à l'heure
des moins de 34 ans qui ne sont pas
allés voter
c'est vous qui pouvez faire la bascule
et vous y avait enterré donc tout ce que
nous allons faire notamment je pense
pour les jeunes à l'allocation
d'autonomie jeunesse que vous nous
voulons mettre en place deux mille 63
euros pour tous les jeunes indépendants
du foyer fiscal de leurs parents ça va
permettre que chacun se préoccupe de ses
études et que de cela et du côté du r n
on espère combien de députés à peu près
alors on a vu le sondage ipsos au plus
bas l'hypothèse c'était 20 députés donc
ce qui serait en fait une des chèques a
priori pour le front national alors que
pas du tout vingt députés c'est encore
un succès le seul objectif du front
national raymond législatives en tout
cas le principal c'est d'obtenir un
minimum 15 députés pour avoir un groupe
parlementaire participé pendant cinq ans
au débat politique à la tête de ce
groupe turquie
marine le pen est donc un parfait
tremplin pour les élections
présidentielles de 2000 27 vous croyez
ça en écoute jordan par mail à notre
objectif en cinq ans dans les cinq
prochaines années pour préparer déjà la
victoire en 2027 et de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait plus aucun français qui nous
perçoivent au travers de la caricature
que certains n'en ont longtemps fait de
nous ah oui c'est vrai qu'avec un groupe
parlementaire puissant l'assemblée ça
nous aiderait déjà 2027 il enjambe le
quinquennat à venir c'est
que des présidentielles à celle de peine
et puis vous avez peut-être de me
demander des nouvelles de l'air parce
que on à willy même vous savez ce que
c'est ils ont fait une campagne très
discrète on pourrait train de la
catastrophe avec le score de pécresse -2
5% la présidentielle en réalité s'en
tire pas si mal que ça il pourra même
sans doute selon ipsos en avoir plus de
sièges finalement que le rassemblement
national mais surtout là où les
républicains sont en embuscade c'est au
cas où macron n'aurait pas la majorité
absolue alors il devrait chercher un
appui quelque part pourquoi pas chez les
républicains donc ça serait assez
avantageux xavier bertrand moi je suis
comme
70% des français je ne souhaite pas que
monsieur macron et une majorité absolue
parce que s'il a une majorité relative
cela veut dire qu'il devra écouter cette
fois ci il devra écouter parce que quand
il décide seul il dessine mal et donc
plus nous aurons député plus nous
pourrons peser notamment en matière de
sécurité et de pouvoir d'achat comme sur
la réforme emblématique des retraites
bon ben voila j'ai donné la parole à
tout le monde maintenant c'est le temps
du débat merci à vous stéphane on va on
va débattre de tout cela avec nos
invités à avant de passer en revue les
différentes stratégies des uns et des
autres dans cet entre-deux tours
j'aimerais vous entendre chacun sur
l'état d'esprit des français aujourd'hui
peut-être on commence par vous laurent
de boissieu stéphane blakowski parler de
cette incertitude qui plane sur le
scrutin que veulent vraiment les
français ce qu'ils ont envie de donner
une majorité absolue à emmanuel macron
dimanche alors moi je vais citer l'ifop
bye bye mais sur les français qui sont
allés voter au premier tour où tous les
cas 55% voulait une cohabitation vol une
cohabitation se dire que je mène ma
qu'on n'ait pas une majorité sont une
semaine ceci dit ça ne dit pas grand
chose parce que ceux qui veulent une
cohabitation
veulent une commission avec des
personnes différentes et on en revient
au problème qui est cette cette vie
politique éclaté avec trois blocs qui
sont entre 20 et 30% donc ce que les
français majoritairement les français
majoritairement ne veulent pas la même
chose oui vous parlez des trois blocs on
les retrouve aussi dans un sondage aux
hawks a publié par le figaro ce matin
sur le souhait des français et on voit
qu'il ya que 25% des français qui valent
une majorité absolue pour emmanuel
macron est alors le figaro prend à
linverse
70% des français ne veulent pas qu
emmanuel macron est une majorité absolue
on retrouve cette tripartition un peu de
de la vie politique aujourd'hui à
travers cette enquête abbas et c'est un
phénomène qui sont un signe il ya vu
qu'on avait une quadri partition avec la
droite les républicains qui sont pas
connues ont disparu mais qui sont
maintenant à un niveau tellement faibles
qu'ils sont très loin des 3 autres blocs
et on a trois blocs et en plus trois
blocs qui sur le fond sont ils des
victimes ont très différents sur le fond
incompatibles parfois il ya on on a pu
voir plusieurs blocs mais avec des des
passerelles possibles ou des coalitions
possibles là on se dit que c'est très
très compliqué impossible que deux de
ces trois blocs
travaillent ensemble les électeurs
peuvent avoir des petits mouvements on
en reparlera certainement on va en
parler catherine tricot nous a rejoint
bonsoir directrice de la revue regards
on va regarder un autre sondage cette
fois le souhait de victoire des français
c'est une enquête publiée aujourd'hui
par ipsos et on voit que il ya une
légère dynamique favorable à emmanuel
macron +2 points 53% qu'il souhaite qu
emmanuel macron obtiennent la majorité
qu'ils puissent appliquer sa politique
et on voit que ça baisse de 2 points du
côté des souhaits de victoire de jean
luc mélenchon
on n'a pas le sentiment qu'il ya une
envie claire de gauche non plus dans ce
scrutin du côté des français la couche
n'est pas majoritaire ça ça me paraît
clair je veux dire on a trois poules par
contre c'est ce que vous venez de
rappeler c'est dire qu'il ya une
minorité de gens qui veulent que les
manuels macro et la majorité or là on va
avoir des scores des scrutins avec deux
candidats le plus souvent un candidat
macro nice face à un candidat d'un autre
genre qui est le plus souvent la nuit
baisse est de temps en temps enfin quand
même 200 fois c'est le candidat du front
national qui sera présent et donc quand
tu auras ce duel la majorité ensemble
face à un autre candidat bas ça peut pas
tourner à l'avantagé à peu ne pas
tourner al'avantage de la république en
marche puisque justement il ya une
majorité de gens qui ne veulent pas
d'une majorité absolue pour amener le
maquereau moi je pense que cette
situation est extrêmement dangereux sert
qu'à pas de majorité pour la gauche a
pas de majorité pour macron n'y a pas de
majorité pour la droite mais le scrutin
qui était avec deux candidats fait que
ça peut être dangereux pour pour
emmanuel macron magath l'ombre et
comment vous analysez vous cette
situation
mais je pense c'est difficile de parler
au nom des français mais je pense que
pour beaucoup de français elles sont ils
vendent plus avoir le choix et de plus
avoir d'alternative et en fait ces trois
grands blocs on voit bien qu'il suscite
tous les trois énormément de rejet même
le bloc central macro nice tu suscites
du rejet des grands partis traditionnels
de la vème république ont été totalement
laminé et les parties vous qualifier
d'extrême en tout cas que la nuée et le
parti de marine le pen aujourd'hui le
mode de scrutin fait qu' ils ont peu de
chances d'arriver au pouvoir donc même
pour ceux qui se reconnaissent dedans
votez pour eux n'est pas forcément la
garantie que leurs idées seront
représentés donc d'une part le sentiment
de pas avoir d'alternative et ensuite on
peut pas dire non plus qu'il ya une
campagne extrêmement clair alors c'est
sûr qu'ils sont tous assez caricaturaux
et que le combat entre la nuque et
emmanuel macron a été extrêmement
clivant est clair maintenant peut-être
que les français auraient aimé qu'on
leur parle plus d'hôpital de pouvoir
d'achat de retraites on voit par exemple
qu emmanuel macron a complètement mis
sous le tapis toutes les mesures un
petit peu difficile qu'il avait dans sa
besace notamment la réforme des
retraites dont on n'entend plus parler
peut-être que les français aussi aurait
aimé qu'on fasse campagne sur des sujets
qui les concernent davantage
arnaud benedetti cette indécision des
français c'est la faute d'une campagne
pas suffisamment sur le fond non ça
vient de très loin ça vient de très loin
si vous voulez en fait y'a pas de
majorité véritablement aimé il ya une
minorité de blocage
la meilleur outil de blocage qui sait
qu'il exprime c'est le bloc central en
fait qui empêche toute autre forme de
constitution d'alliances qui seraient
susceptibles de construire une
alternative crédible à emmanuel macron
et à sa majorité il ya un quatrième
langue dont on parle peu quand même
ce quatrième bloc c'est les
abstentionnistes j'en parlais le on a
quand même on l'a quand même atteint un
record d'abstention lors de cette
dernière élection législative dont tout
ceci est très compliqué mais si vous
voulez moi je pense qu'en fait la
décomposition de la vie politique et sa
recomposition sont pas achevées elles
ont commencé largement 2010 elle a
commencé largement en 2017 elle se
poursuit en 2022 et ce qui rend si vous
voulez d'autant plus à certains
finalement le résultat de dimanche c'est
que justement cette décomposition elle
va favoriser si vous voulez des
situations locales dans un certain
nombre de circonscriptions qu'ils
peuvent les unes boutabout avoir un
impact sur le résultat final c'est à
dire qu'en fait les facteurs locaux vont
aussi jouer un rôle important dans le
choix que les électeurs vont pouvoir
faire dimanche lors du second tour
également donc ça aussi c'est un facteur
qui disent ont constitué une incertitude
supplémentaire ensuite ce que veulent
les français il suffit de regarder vous
avez un certain nombre d'études
d'opinion vous voyez les items qui sont
les items dominant dans cette élection
législative ce sont à peu près les mêmes
que ceux des élections présidentielles
c'est le pouvoir d'achat c'est la santé
c'est l'environnement et éventuellement
les questions régaliennes qui arrive
assez assez largement dit pas ce qu'il
faut faire non
on va on va se pencher sur le cas des
abstentionnistes dont vous dont vous
parliez puisqu'il constitue un peu la
principale réserve de voix qui pourrait
faire basculer ce scrutin ils ont fait
l'objet de toutes les attentions pendant
cet entre-deux-tours comment est-ce
qu'il réagisse à cette forme de danse du
ventre un des différents candidats
nicolas coadou et antoine coûte 1 se
sont rendus à lens dans le pas-de-calais
c'est l'une des villes où l'on a le
moins voté en france au premier tour
c'est une ville qui boudent les urnes à
lens dans le pas de calais deux
électeurs sur trois sont restés chez eux
dimanche dernier nous sommes partis à
leur rencontre pour tenter de comprendre
pourquoi est-ce que vous votez vous mais
pourquoi
est-ce que vous votez par exemple les
élections législatives
pourquoi marie 46 ans depuis dès 18 ans
et aucun changement ce soit à droite
gauche c'est pareil passons
mes convictions même laver les
convictions et même les partis qui
étaient censés représenter mes
convictions j'ai l'impression que
croissance ici la nuque et le
rassemblement national s'affrontent au
deuxième tour alors pour récupérer les
voix des abstentionnistes
les partis politiques multiplient les
appels du pied des grands choix ne se
font jamais par l'abstention elle donc à
votre bon sens et au sursaut républicain
moi je mets peluche la vie pour
supprimer parcours supinfo du bien de
donner le coup de main bouge toi un peu
fait quelque chose à part pleurnicher ou
rester à la maison à rien faire
vous en pensez-quoi end ça c'est du
grand grand mélenchon et du mensonge
c'est toujours du globe l'homme ayant
appris que jamais rien quoique là en
voyant ce genre de vidéos par exemple
vous ça vous donne envie d'aller voter
avant je pense que j'aurais été deuxième
tour dans quelques jours
et à quelques jours du second tour la
méthode privilégiée par les militants
aller chercher les abstentionnistes
jusque chez eux je vous appelle à voter
pour dimanche nous sommes avec le maire
pour la gauche est ce qu'aujourd'hui à
ces gens qui disent moi ça sert à rien
d'aller voter que je vote à droite à
gauche mais finalement elle change pas
on a beaucoup entendu ça qu'est ce qu'on
leur réponde non répond par des réponses
ici sur des actions terrain des actions
du quotidien qui les préoccupent voilà
dans leur vie de tous les jours quelque
part après c'est aussi difficiles des
moments de connecter ces actions-là par
rapport à des enjeux qui sont des enjeux
nationaux dans cette circonscription la
semaine dernière 58% des électeurs se
sont abstenus
agathe saint brais on sent que ça va pas
être facile quand même de les convaincre
ces abstentionnistes d'aller d'aller
voter dimanche vous y croyez vous un
sursaut de participation
j'ai du mal à imaginer qu'ils un sursaut
de participation dans et que la donne
change fondamentalement entre le premier
et le second tour en revanche c'était
c'est vital pour jean luc mélenchon
parce qu'il a déjà réussi à faire
l'union de la gauche il a plus vraiment
de réserve aux ordres contrairement à
emmanuel macron qui pourrait aller
chercher sur la droite ou sur la gauche
raisonnable
entre guillemets et donc mélenchon on le
voit sermonne les jeunes les secoue un
peu et un côté jeunes ont voté
massivement pour lui au premier tour 42
% il me semble selon l'ipsos et en même
temps les jeunes se sont abstenus mais
70% il me semble donc nettement plus que
la moyenne nationale
ce qui est assez dramatique et donc jean
luc mélenchon dans cet entre-deux-tours
essaye voilà d'aller convaincre les
abstentionnistes je sais pas si ce sera
très payant au final catherine frécaut
vous y croyez vous cette mobilisation
des jeunes en faveur de lannux je ne
sais pas ce que ça va produire mais en
tout cas il ya c'est certain que c'est
là que se trouve l'essentiel de la
réserve les réserves de voix pour la
nuque et en plus elles sont sur
l'ensemble du territoire c'est à cette
question de l'abstention des jeunes
c'est général dira qu' il ya 400
candidats c'est pas simplement dans les
bastions c'est sur la totalité du
territoire français il ya des jeunes à
sortir aller en est votée et moi je
crois qu'il ya une petite chance que ça
marche parce qu'il ya une simplification
au second tour c'est à dire que là il ya
deux candidats et donc c'est quand même
plus simple quand on ne suit pas le
détail de la vie politique surtout que
ce sont des nouveaux noms qui sont
apparus ensemble
la nuque on connaît pas donc là au moins
il ya une espèce de simplification on a
un candidat
macron un candidat mélenchon en gros ou
alors un camp d' à marine le pen si dans
la simplification du second tour va à
mon avis aider ceux qui sont les moins
impliqués qui suivent le moins la vie
politique vous l'avez remarqué donc
votre reportage le maire eddie la gauche
rassemblée c'est terrible il emploie pas
le nom de lannux de la nuque septembre
encore entré comme ensemble changer de
nom en voilà entre deux élections quand
même et donc la voilà je pense que cette
simplification va permettre aux plus
jeunes de s'y retrouver je l'espère sur
cette question de la participation des
jeunes croient que lacroix a fait sa une
aujourd'hui là-dessus justement oui
c c'est quoi la clé pour mobiliser cet
électorat qui s'abstient la difficulté
c'est que c'est un électorat c'est pas
une abstention
les jeunes ça resterait là qui est
structurellement absentionnistes donc il
ya multi-facteurs
mais juste revenir sur la question de la
simplification la signification on peut
aussi faire plus d'attention pourquoi
parce que concrètement il ya deux
candidats dans les cas dément tout et
que ces concessions quelques
triangulaire mais on croisait des
visuels partout donc il ya beaucoup
d'électeurs dont leur propre tournée
plus présents et parmi eux beaucoup vont
s'abstenir donc il ya je pense qu'au
contraire un risque d'une abstention
plus importante au second tour par
ailleurs il assure la jonction une
question il ya la pratique à la théorie
c'est à dire que en théorie on sait bien
qu'à une solution différenciée les
jeunes s'abstiennent plus les personnes
âgées votre plus les catégories sociales
populaires sa chienne plus dégradés
social
a de plus intellectuel et diplômés
saptel moi lecteur marine le pen s'est
abstenu à 58% whist hâtif apporte de la
présidentielle alors sur une macro et
vos thèses 64% par rapport à la
présidentielle donc on voit bien qui a
des réserves de voix mais ça c'est la
théorie parce qu'en pratique on
s'aperçoit que lorsque une abstention
augmente dans une élection en gros
il ya une sorte d dilution et ça profite
un peu être à tout le monde sait qu'on
n'est jamais un grand vainqueur il ya
jusqu'à présent
jamais eu un grand vainqueur si on va
dire je vais gagner parce que je vais
mobiliser c'est surtout nist c'est un
bon discours de campagne ça permet de se
dire qu on encore lire nr doigt mais
dans la pratique ça ne se vérifient
jamais alors j'aimerais quand même vous
entendre vous à arnaud benedetti avec
d'abord un chiffre c'est la prévision
justement de l'abstention pour le second
tour fait par ipsos bon un taux de
participation autour de 47% ce serait
quasiment stable mais il y aurait pas de
décrochage en 2017 y avait eu un gros
décrochage et j'aimerais juste qu'on
voit aussi une autre infographie qui
montre les législatives au fil au fil du
temps et on se rend compte qu'il n'y a
pu y avoir des sursauts de participation
quand il y avait un fort enjeu
électoral ça a été le cas en 97 ça a
donné lieu à une cohabitation entre
lionel jospin et jacques chirac dans 88
quand michel rocard s'est retrouvé avec
une majorité relative est ce qu'on est
potentiellement dans ce cas de figure
aujourd'hui si vous voulez la réalité
c'est qu'il ya une polarisation qui a
été finalement et c'est le grand succès
de jean luc mélenchon orchestrée par
jean luc mélenchon en fait c'est lui ou
c'est emmanuel macron donc là on a un
effet simplificateur pour l'électorat
qui peut se traduire pour le second tour
d'autant plus que les résultats du
premier tour pour la gauche sont des
résultats si ce n'est ici ne sont pas
tout à fait à la hauteur de ce
qu'attendent et jean luc mélenchon mais
qui sont quand même encourageant pour la
gauche lors la simplification allait
quand même relative parce que quand vous
regardez le nombre de duels finalement
il ya beaucoup de duels certes entre la
gauche et
est ensemble il ya à peu près 200 sont
dix duels mais vous avez d'autres
situations vous avez des situations où
il s'agit parfois de candidats du
rassemblement national contre des
candidats de gauche ou des candidats du
candidats
de d'emmanuel macron il y en a une
centaine à peu près donc c'est une
simplification quand même relative
ensuite c'est vrai qu'il peut y avoir
des effets correctifs aussi on a vu
souvent dans des élections légistatives
des effets correctifs 2 de second tour
par rapport à un 1er tour je rappellerai
2007 notamment souvenez vous en 2007 on
s'attendait à ce que la majorité
sarkozyste soit beaucoup plus large
qu'elle ne les quelques elle ne le
furent au résultat puisque il ya eu à
peu près une trentaine ou une
quarantaine de parlementaires ou deux
candidats qui était donné gagnant à
droite qui ont mordu la poussière dont à
l'époque d'ailleurs alain juppé il faut
s'en souvenir donc il peut toujours y
avoir des effets correctifs la réalité
c'est que là
il ya quand même des tendances qui sont
assez lourdes depuis le premier tour et
on voit mal quel est l'effet correctifs
qui pourrait finalement surgir dans un
sens ou dans un autre ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on a compris globalement que
l'objectif de la majorité absolue pour
les maquereaux nist serait quand même
très difficile à atteindre et que l'on a
compris également que l'objectif qui
était l'objectif j'allais dire
matricielle de jean luc mélenchon serait
quand même très difficile à atteindre
aussi donc alors c'est un effet oui
c'est un effet c'est à dire que ça peut
par exemple démobiliser une partie de
l'électorat conservateur qui auraient
peur finalement d'une victoire de la
gauche se disant les risques sont
finalement modérée peut-être qu'on va
pas aller faire la courte échelle aux
candidats macro nist ça aussi ça peut
jouer dans ce sens mais enfin en tout
cas ça sera difficile on va se pencher
si vous pouvez bien sûr la stratégie
cette fois des manuels macron dans cet
entre deux tours avec ce choix de saab
stante de s'absenter du pays pendant
quatre jours quasiment 1 pour se rendre
en roumanie en moldavie puis finalement
en ukraine agathon bref vous l'avez
suivi emmanuel macron dans ce périple
européen
c'est un pari risqué selon vous de
s'absenter de quitter la scène politique
nationale comme ça un moment clé en tout
cas même dans son entourage même chez
les maquereaux nist quand certains ont
découvert que le président allait partir
quasiment toute la semaine dans
l'entre-deux-tours ils n'ont pas compris
et donc certains lui ont dit il faudrait
quand même que tu prennes la parole
avant de partir il faut absolument que
tu envoies un message tu peux pas te
contenter de ça et on a vu donc emmanuel
macron improvisé alors bon ça faisait
deux trois jours qu'ils pensaient
s'exprimer avant de partir mais quand
même s'exprimer depuis le tarmac de
l'aéroport d'orly juste avant de
décoller donc emmanuel macron qui
s'exprime pour parler des législatives
envoyer un message en se posant comme le
garant de la république le garant de
l'ordre dans un monde bouleversé par la
guerre pour mieux se distinguer de jean
luc mélenchon qui incarnerait le chaos
et madame apprend on assume totalement
le mélange des genres en fait et parce
que deux secondes après et d'écoles pour
aller en roumanie et pour la se poser en
chef de guerre chef des armées je ne
sais pas si ça aura des effets dans
l'est surnommé en tout cas la ficelle de
communication est peut-être un peu
grosse même si on ne peut pas critiquer
l'utilité de ce déplacement on m'a
reproché à émana monde
de se rendre aux portes de la guerre en
europe il peut y avoir un effet drapeau
comme on dit comme le disait stéphane
blakowski c'est-à-dire
sorte de rassemblement autour du chef de
l'état en période de guerre où ça c'est
fini tu l'écris glissait de l'hémisphère
sud notamment sur l'agora qui
l'entourage et qui votent beaucoup qui
est très légitimiste donc il peut y
avoir un effet de repos ce qui est assez
étonnant c'est que et on s'est mis en
tête que pour ses initiatives il y avait
un devoir une période de réserve pour
les ministres alors certes il faut pas
confondre lorsque le ministre étant
fonction paraissent qualité entre
ministres et fait campagne mais quand
même les ministres l'après ministre les
ministres ils demandent quand même aux
français d'ordonner une majorité pour
poursuivre leur travail est il normal
aussi qu'ils annoncent qu'ils vont faire
en revanche le chef de l'état lui il a
il ya un mélange des genres il est pas
le chef de la majorité c'est pas
seulement ceux qui sont qui devrait être
au front en avant dans la campagne
hâtives hier les ministres les prémices
où l on entend pas tant que ça et je me
tate à qui lui devrait être au-dessus
mais législatives lui on entend pas on
l'entend on l'entend lui on l'a entendu
lapsus révélateur de de l' inverse de ce
qui s'est passé arnaud benedetti jean
françois copé qui est pourtant plutôt
favorables à un soutien ponctuel à
emmanuel macron a eu cette phrase la
maison brûle et emmanuel macron regarde
ailleurs il parle d'une stratégie
d'évitement il dit c'est une folie de
partir comme ça à l'étranger en plein
entre-deux tours je suis de ceux qui
pensent que sa fille un long très peu
d'impact si emmanuel macron pense que il
va y avoir un effet drapeau comme vous
venez de le dire autour de sa personne
et au tour des candidats de sa majorité
suite à ce voyage je pense qu'ils se
trompent lors des faits il ya eu si vous
voulez la crise ukrainienne a joué un
rôle essentiel dans la dans l'anesthésié
de la campagne présidentielle
parce que c'était un moment sidérant
pour une grande partie de l'opinion
publique mais sauf que si vous voulez la
relation aujourd'hui à ce qui se passe
en ukraine n'est plus tout à fait la
même du point de vue de l'opinion
que ce qu'elle était il ya trois mois
donc les choses ont aussi quand même
considérablement évolué et de ce point
de vue donc moi je crois pas du tout à
l'impact si vous voulez alors que ce
soit intentionnel de la part d' emmanuel
macron certainement parce que la preuve
en est en train d'en parler et pendant
qu'on en parle on ne parle pas
finalement des enjeux qui sont des
enjeux et domestiques donc de ce point
de vue c'est réussi mais est-ce que ça a
un impact dans le comportement des
électeurs vraisemblablement
vraisemblement très peu
4 et rigoriste oralement peut-être pas
d'effet mais médiatiquement ça ça un peu
étouffé les campagnes que ses
adversaires et je passe à étouffer mais
politiquement je pense que ça a un effet
parce qu'en 2000 il met tous les
attributs du pouvoir et de la puissance
derrière lui un il ya le drapeau
tricolore ya l'avion mec marqué en gros
république française il fait son crime
sa déclaration est qu'est-ce qu'il dit
dans sa déclaration pourquoi tu peux
donner ses suffrages pour la république
il appelle à un sursaut républicain
ça c'est ça ça c'est très important je
veux dire ségala le la forme le contexte
qui est le contenu de ce qu'il raconte
alors on va en parler mais j'aimerais
juste d'abord qu'on écoute justement la
réaction les réactions de marine le pen
et d'olivier fort à cet appel lancé
depuis l'aéroport d'orly un sursaut
républicain
écouter quels outrance quel outrance
comment peut-on imaginer désormais on et
macro nist où on est antirépublicain et
à force de convoquer des arguments
d'autorité de cette nature il laisse
penser que le pays serait désormais en
proie à des anti républicain partout
c'est une folie il sous-entendait que
l'intégralité de ses opposants en
réalité n'était pas dans la république
il faut arrêter avec ça on ne joue pas
avec ces concepts lacs sont des concepts
extrêmement important on ne peut il ne
peut pas traiter tous ceux qui
s'opposent à lui vous êtes senti visé
directement non mais il a visé tout le
monde d'ailleurs tout le monde bon
d'anti républicain c'est honteux
c'est une folie c'est honteux ils ont
raison de s'insurger avec ces termes je
pense que c'est une folie mais je pense
que c'est une folie pour la raison
inverse en fait marine le pen a bien
raison de se faire de la porte parole de
tout le monde c'est dire que d'une
certaine manière ça la met dans l'eau et
les traiter à égalité avec olivier faur
ça veut dire qu'en fait cette attaque
contre tous ceux qui ne seraient pas ma
chronique qui serait anti républicain ça
banalise complètement marine le pen et
le en national le rassemblement national
ce que je crois être vraiment la
victoire de cette législative alors un
des enseignements tête législatives
c'est que finalement ils réussissent à
rentrer dans le jeu véritablement c'est
à dire que là on met à égalité donc y
aurait les extrêmes il y aurait les
antirépublicain et on met à égalité le
pauvre olivier faure qui n'en peut mais
je veux dire est que marine le pen en
fait c'est hallucinant a girl en bref
sur cette stratégie-là de de considérer
que l'union des gauches finalement elle
n'est pas forcément républicaine dans
sont en tout cas dans son intégralité
celle ça laisse plus grand monde dans
l'arc républicain
oui je pense que c'est assez dangereux
comme stratégie de prétendre incarner le
camp de la république le camp de la
raison et de mettre tous les autres dans
un champ or républicain je pense que les
français détestent qu'on leur dicte ce
qu'ils ont à faire est par ailleurs non
pas par ailleurs emmanuel macron se
trompe en pensant qu'il va pouvoir
gouverner en soulignant cette fracture
je pense qu'il faudrait au contraire
rassembler les français et pas entériner
le fait que le pays est fracturée qu'il
le veuille ou non il a été élu dans un
contexte marqué de très très forte
abstention marquée par le mak et marine
le pen était très très haut et marquée
par un appel au front républicain aussi
c'est à dire laurent de boissieu est ce
que on peut se permettre de dire ça de
l'union des gauches après l'avoir appelé
à faire barrage à marine le pen au
second tour de la présidentielle s'est
quand même contradictoires mais le le
fond de la question c'est qu'en effet
pour des raisons de communication
politique mais c'est pas tout à fait
nouveau il ya une volonté de mettre un
signe égal entre la france est soumise
élargi la nuit baisse aujourd'hui nuque
et et de côté leur assemblée nationale
c'est une stratégie politique qui en
effet peut s'avérer dangereuse parce que
s'ils auront on dit qu'il n'ya que nous
mâcon qui parle pour le centre qui
représente la république et tous les
autres sont anti républicain
démocratie pour rebondir ce que vous
disiez ils sont pas tous d'accord entre
eux chez emmanuel macron fait débat au
sein de la majorité jean michel blanck
caire il le dit l'extrême gauche c'est
pareil que l'extrême droite lui tient un
signe égal entre les deux alors que pour
clément boon qui est issu de la gauche
qu'est ministre des affaires européennes
pour lui c'est pas la même chose ils
refusent de le faire donc en fait cette
campagne encore une fois mises en
lumière les clivages au sein du
maquereau ni ce que l'on raconte
d'ailleurs d'en être vivre et on le
raconte on raconte comment ces clivages
ont explosé pendant la campagne des
présidentielles et aujourd'hui ça
continue pour les législatives et ça
n'augure rien de bon pour ce quinquennat
parce que la vérité c'est qu'on n'a
toujours pas compris quel était le cap
du second mandat d' emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron a le plus grand mal à
essayer d'expliquer ce qu'il veut de ce
qu'il veut faire sur ce monde et tout va
dépendre aussi du verdict des urnes le
dimanche donc c'est difficile d'en
débattre là aujourd'hui mais laurent de
pardon nous benedetti c'est un jeu
dangereux de la part des manuels macron
jouer c'est toujours dangereux politique
de s'arroger nouveau pont de la
république que là en l'occurrence c'est
dangereux en effet parce que si vous
voulez ça at il souligné d'énormes
contradictions vous ne pouvez pas
considérer un jour quand vous en avez
besoin que jean luc mélenchon est un
républicain et si je me bats bus c'est
bien ce qu'avait dit emmanuel macron
lors des élections présidentielles dans
l'entre-deux tours des élections et puis
lorsque vous en avez plus besoin c'est à
dire lorsque vous affrontez à lui le
ranger dans les adversaires du régime
républicain il ya une contradiction qui
apparaît à tous ceux qui peuvent
observer sans être véritablement des
spécialistes la vie politique en
l'occurrence donc cette contradiction
elle est très forte mais c'est toute
l'ambiguïté si vous voulez en fin de
compte du maquereau disent même acronis
me veut et ça c'est un vrai problème
aujourd'hui sur le plan j'allais dire
sur le plan du fonctionnement
démocratique il veut bloquer toute
possibilité d'alternance et si vous
voulez vous ne pouvez pas dans un régime
démocratique
à un moment donné dire que ceux qui vous
sont
qui ce qui vous sont opposés ne peuvent
pas finalement être des alternatives
crédibles et ça c'est une difficulté qui
à mon sens majeur avant d'aborder la
stratégie d'entre deux tours de jean luc
mélenchon j'aimerais qu'on dise un mot
d'elisabeth bornes elle a vu un peu
monté au front en l'absence d' emmanuel
macron comment vous avez jugé sa
prestation de chef de la majorité
agathe l'ambré je pense que clairement
depuis depuis qu'elle a été nommé à
matignon il avait devant n'imprime pas
vraiment donc voilà c'est l'expression
qui revient dans man of dans la majorité
il ya vraiment des mots parfois très dur
on a lu dans le canard enchaîné
responsables de la majorité dire qu'elle
a le charisme d'un gastéropode
ouais ça va jusque là c'est toujours de
façon anonyme pour l'instant mais qu'est
ce que vous voulez emmanuel macron une
techno a succédé à un techno emmanuel
macron depuis edouard philippe a tout
fait et ça aussi on raconte dans le
livre pour choisir des gens dans son
entourage et en particulier à matignon
qui n'imprime pas parce que tout doit
procéder de lui et toute façon elisabeth
borne est là et elle essaye de faire
campagne mais la réalité c'est que
emmanuel macron ne compte que sur
lui-même pour faire campagne contre pas
sur sa première ministre on se souvient
nicolas sarkozy qui traitait de françois
fillon prémices de collaborateurs mais
c'est la même logique pour emmanuel
macron c'est à dire qu en effet tout
remonte à l'elysée pour ma fille on
savait à notre point quand même pardon
de dire que françois fillon il était un
homme politique avait déjà à passer un
poids politique
des premières
marques est là elle est là depuis
quelques épreuves et elle était là elle
a fait tout le quinquennat précédent
elle n'avait pas comme on dit imprimé
c'est à dire que les français ne l'avait
pas repérées on ne sait pas bien la
situer éventuellement on se rappelle
qu'elle avait quand même toucher aux
allocations chômage est là et qu'il a
rendus très très dur enfin je veux dire
c'est quand même une femme très dur sur
le plan social c'est elle qui choisit
comme premier ministre mais elle
politiquement on ne la sent pas on ne
sait pas qui elle est et il ne l'a pas
choisie c'est pas on ne le découvre pas
si on le savait qu'elle ne préparait pas
et donc c'est bien pour cette raison là
qu'elle a été choisie ce qui est
totalement étrange parce quand même
emmanuel macron des bien falloir qu'ils
l'acceptent à la fois qu'il sait 120
qu'il est président mais c'est son
dernier mandat donc c'est quand même
étrange de comme façon de préparer de
préparer la suite à l'air de vouloir
tout accaparé pas de partis pas de
premier ministre je décide de tout bon
bah donc après lui le déluge et en plus
pas d'opposition républicaine alors je
veux dire je sais pas ce qu'ils
préparent mais c'est un désastre on va
se pencher sur l'union des gauches la
nuque à présent on s'est rendu dans une
circonscription où le député sortant
jean françois mbaye est membre de la
majorité est sous la menace d'une jeune
candidate de la france insoumise en
l'occurrence clémence gaieté c'est un
reportage dans le val de marne demarco
pommiers et andré lafon
et
bien
elle a frôlé la barre des 50% dès le
premier tour clémence gaieté candidate
de la nuque c'est la victoire à portée
de main mais face aux 60% d'abstention
dans la circonscription elle continue
d'aller au contact
ce jour là avec alexis corbière figure
de la france insoumise et l'accueil est
plutôt bon ça fait plusieurs semaines
que l'accueil est très bon sur ce marché
c'est le cas dans tous les marchés
le quartier populaire les gens savent
d'un championnat de la figure de jean
luc moyens sont bons à la madrague
jean luc mélenchon
jean luc mélenchon une figure populaire
dans cette 2e circonscription du val de
marne qui votent historiquement à gauche
votez pour clément ici le programme de
la nuque c'est carton plein nos
propositions voilà font écho à ce que
vivent les gens ici c'est à dire que ils
ont des problèmes de pouvoir d'achat ils
ont des problèmes parce que les loyers
commence à monter doucement et que ça
devient parfois ingérable
les cinq années passées ils ont élu un
député qui a voté voilà tous les projets
du gouvernement il ya une grosse
déception déception une critique qui
visent directement jean-françois mbye
lui défend le bilan du gouvernement
dimanche le député sortant de la
majorité accusaient un retard de 24
points sur son adversaire alors même si
la marche semble haute pour l'emporter
au second tour il continue d'y croire
mais il faut toujours être confiée en
politique faut jamais être défaitiste ne
serait ce que pour nos électeurs si on
commence à être défaitiste nos électeurs
qui nous ont fait confiance au premier
tour on les travaille et un petit peu
d'emplois de confiance jusqu'au bout
pour renverser la dynamique le candidat
macro nice tu veux convaincre les
abstentionnistes
convaincre aussi du projet illusoire de
jean luc mélenchon sur la question de la
du semis pour tout le monde à 1500 euros
sur la question
un projet irréalisable et même
irresponsable
d'après le candidat c'est dangereux
aujourd'hui de francs être aux gens la
retraite à 60 ans
le smic à 1500 euros moi je veux dire où
est ce qu'on voit et cet argument il
fonctionne auprès des électeurs dans
cette série c'est ce qu'on essaye de en
tout cas de faire c'est ce qu'on essaie
de provoquer c'est ce qu'on les voyait
bien la dame avec qui j'ai discuté
allant lire je pense consciente jean
françois et mbaye contre clémence gaieté
deux incarnations pour deux visions de
la france avec un débat qui se
poursuivra sur les bancs de l'assemblée
durant les cinq prochaines années 4
entre qu on est sur un cas de figure
exceptionnel vous pensez une
circonscription aux mains de la majorité
qui pourraient tomber aux mains de la
gauche ou alors c'est une
circonscription traditionnellement de
gauche se servir que donc ils sont pas
en terrain enfin je veux dire semaine
circonscriptions de droite que la gauche
devrait reprendre ses créteil c'est une
ville populaire assez mixte voilà donc
ce que je pense c'est que là il peut y
avoir un effet opportunité de battre
emmanuel macron c'est à dire que ce
qu'on dit tout à l'heure il ya une belge
orité de français qui veulent pas que
emmanuel macron et une majorité absolue
et quand j'ai dit tout à l'heure ça
simplifie les choses là c'est simple
c'est vous voulez emmanuel macron vous
avez un candidat vous voulez pas
emmanuel macron vous avez un candidat et
donc cette simplification je pense que
en particulier dans les circonscriptions
qui sont populaires ça va fonctionner
comment on va parler un peu de jean luc
mélenchon à présent comment vous jugez
sa campagne d'entre deux tours
c'est une campagne qui est finalement
conforme à ce qui était déjà ça qu'on
veut sa campagne de premier tour il n'a
pas varié j'allais dire d'un iota dans
sa ligne depuis finalement cette idée
qui a été une idée géniale sur le plan
politique de vouloir faire de ces
élections législatives le troisième tour
des élections présidentielles il reste
dans ce sillon il n'en démord pas et il
continue on le voit à 10 rue de soissons
qui sera premier ministre lundi ou mardi
puisque le président de la république
n'aura pas d'autre choix que de celui de
la plaie alors maintenant on sent bien
que il faut qu'il aille chercher les
électeurs avec les dents comme on dit
lorsqu'on est dans une bataille
électorale et que c'est bien évidemment
l'appel aux jeunes l'appel aux
abstentionnistes qui pour lui est
absolument essentiel parce que ce qui va
être très important par rapport à ce
qu'on a vu du reportage c'est que toute
situation locale est assez différente
lorsque vous avez un candidat de gauche
qui est largement en tête disons ses
chances de l'emporter sont disons
vraisemblable lorsque c'est à
touche-touche avait de plus compliqué
parce que le problème de l'algue 0
jaguar c'est le problème c'est la
réserve de voix et c'est justement
qu'elle va être encore une fois
l'attitude des républicains l'électorat
républicain ou de l'électorat du
rassemblement national et on voit bien
que selon les circonscriptions
l'électorat du rassemblement national
pourra dans certaines circonscriptions
aller voter pour le candidat de lannux
ou dans d'autres circonstances
s'abstenir ou aller voter et
éventuellement pour le candidat opposé à
lantin au camp des loges je pense que là
c'est une constitution juste un peu de
monsieur castaner on sait très bien que
monsieur castaner est dans le viseur il
est dans le viseur même de l'état major
du rassemblement national louis aliot a
appelé à le faire battre et donc à voter
pour l'union des gauches
laurent de boissieu sur ce sujet des
réserves de voix de la nuque est-ce que
l'électorat du r'n une partie de son
électorat peut constituer une réserve de
voix quand il ya plus de candidats fn au
second tour alors je vais redire en
effet on a on a des cas très différents
mais alors pas dans la circonscription
la con qu'on a vu en fait c'est plutôt
un rééquilibrage par rapport à 2010 est
qui va se passer dans cette danse est
conscient de cette circonscription la
dans d'autres endroits au contraire oui
il peut y avoir un électorat populaire
un jérôme sainte-marie le politologue à
a théorisé l'idée d'un bloc élitaire
cantal banques populaires et de fait le
bloc populaire alors ce sera pas tout
l'électorat et rennes bien entendu on a
une idée de la proportion partie non ce
qui est très divisé c'est que on fait
des sondages nationaux on a des ddd mais
on voit ce qui peut se passer d'un sauna
les sondages mais en fait ce sont 172
qu'elle s'inquiétait au premier tour
scrutin différent c'est une action
nationale mesterrieux territorialisées
c'est la difficulté pour jean luc
mélenchon ce qui est très important pour
cette initiative c'est la question de
des rapports internes à la gauche ça
serait ça va être la première fois
depuis 1956 qu'au sein de la gauche la
force socialiste et ses filles opus ps
ne sera plus la force dominante
concrètement au second tour au stand ups
1 60 % des candidats qui sont issus de l
efi 15 % issus de élevé et qu'un sport
sont issus du ps
l'art c'est le premier gros enjeu pour
mélenchon ancien à gauche le second
enjeu c'est que c'est fait ça elle est
finie mais là ça va c'est gratuit
évidemment parlement et ce qui signifie
que l efi première force d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale euh c'est pas si
on en parlait mais ça peut avoir des
conséquences très différentes par
rapport à ce qui était l'opposition des
républicains par rapport aux menaces
dans la pression du statut rester là
qu'un qui était la première force
d'opposition parlementaire on n'y est
pas encore on va attendre le vote de
dimanche effectivement à quatre membres
et d'un mot quand même quand jean luc
mélenchon s'adresse aux fâchez pas facho
mais très fâché donc ça c'est la
deuxième version parce qu'il l'a fait un
premier lapsus dont il s'est excusé
d'ailleurs mais justice qui quand il dit
ça paye vise les électeurs de marine le
pen on est d'accord alain saint louis et
jean luc mélenchon a fait une campagne
assez génial on peut le dire il a quand
même été éliminé au premier tour il a
réussi dans cette campagne législative à
se faire passer pour le deuxième homme
alors aidé assez paradoxalement par
marine le pen qui elle est partie
complètement défaitiste et a prétendu
sous couvert de dire la vérité à ses
électeurs mais en tout cas elle est
partie battu journée jean luc mélenchon
a bien géré et quand bien même il ne
serait pas premier ministre il n'est pas
une approximation
près et effectivement son groupe à
l'assemblée pourrait passer de 17
députés soit à une centaine il me semble
aujourd'hui une centaine ce qui serait
mais absolument énorme donc en fait
aujourd'hui jean-luc mélenchon il a
quand même réussi son pari et sera pas
premier ministre mais c'est lui qui a
donné le tempo de cette campagne je
t'adore très vite et après on va passer
au salon national ce que je pense c'est
qu'il va y avoir énormément des députés
et les filles et énormément de jeunes
sert des députés et les filles sont des
gens jeunes c'est dire si des gens qui
ont entre 30 et 40 ans qui sont hyper
fort mais hyper militants et je pense
que ce qu'ils ont fait en effet pendant
le premier camp quinquennat à 17 c'est
une multiplie par 6 s'affaissait ça va
faire du bruit à l'assemblée oui et
maniema preuve avec maniable accros
peuvent être sentir passer ils ont
travaillé ils ont fait des contrecoups
des gros budget des comptes proposition
doit non plus que d'autres guest
d'opposition ils étaient beaucoup moins
nombreux que la droite et ils ont été
beaucoup plus entendu que la droite sert
qui sont en capacité de travail et de se
saisir de toutes les opportunités pour
contester le pouvoir
voilà ça promet entre guillemets ça
promet de l'ambiance est
un peu agitée en tout cas ça promet
qu'il y aura une opposition on va on va
se pencher sur le rassemblement national
à présent il est présent dans 208
circonscription au second tour s'ils ont
quasiment doublé à l'heure le résultat
par rapport à 2010 est c'est la seule
force politique qui a progressé assez
fortement d'ailleurs par rapport à 2010
est tout le problème maintenant est
passée un peu de transformer l'essai
arnaud benedetti quelles sont les
réserves de voix potentielles du
rassemblement de nationale aujourd'hui
là aussi encore une fois je vais lire
tout dépend des circonscriptions vous
avez des circonscriptions ou lorsqu'ils
sont opposés finalement à au candidat de
la majorité ils peuvent espérer en effet
éventuellement avoir des réserves de
voix du côté de l'électorat de gauche le
plus anti mac road east clairement
lorsqu'ils sont opposés à des candidats
qui sont des candidats de lannux ils
vont être là pour le coup aller et cher
ils vont essayer d'aller chercher les
voix qui à droite notamment chez les
conservateurs ou chez l'électorat macro
nist peuvent éventuellement vouloir
envoie avoir envie de faire barrage au
candidat de gauche donc il ya quand même
des réserves de voix vous avez raison de
rappeler que finalement c'est la seule
force politique qui progresse d'un
scrutin à l'autre par rapport à 2010 est
surtout ils progressent non seulement
dans leurs bastions ça c'est très
important on voit dans le pas de calais
choix qu'ils ont douze candidats qui
sont en mesure qu'ils seront tous pros
second tour et également dans le sud est
mais aussi dans des bastions levon les
attendait moins même si nationalement
envoyés qu'au niveau des élections
présidentielles il progressiez sud ouest
par exemple c'est très intéressant le
voici sur gironde ne sont pas en mesure
de gagner en gironde ils sont en mesure
d'en placer deux sur trois voire trois
sur trois dans le lot-et-garonne vous
voyez bien que là il ya quand même
quelque chose qui eux un enracinement
une vue en tout cas dans des termes
comme un succès et le fait de ramener un
groupe parlementaire à l'assemblée
nationale après
le dernier groupe parlementaire s'était
1986 qui plus est avec un scrutin
proportionnel en effet ce point de vue
là c'est un gain politique pour le
rassemblement national et pour pour sa
présidente et elle sera à l'assemblée
elle elle va être élu jean-luc mélenchon
ne le sera pas c'est quand même assez
important cercle comme elle aura un
groupe elle aura un temps paroles bien
plus important c'est qu'elle pourra
s'exprimer sur tous les sujets
importants et elle sera enfin moi je
pense qu'elle balcon mais le président
eh oui le présidera est elle donc elle
sera la réunion des présidents et elle
interviendra surtout des sujets qu'elle
croit bon de porter et donc ça ça va ça
va s'entendre ça va donner de la voix
alors qu'actuellement il avait trop peu
de députés pour être entendu il pouvait
même pas parlé tandis que là ils vont
pouvoir parler et la cerise sur le
gâteau si je puis dire peau pour le pour
le et rennes seraient c'est pas gagné
d'avancé mais c'est pas impossible on
regarde les sondages et dans les
descriptions serait d'avoir le même
nombre d'élus que les républicains alors
sérieusement parce que toute la droite
qui ont ajouté les républicains ludique
cera mais que les républicains seul
c'est pas impossible d'un mot quand même
on a un peu raillé la stratégie de
campagne de marine le pen ou s est
absenté pendant deux semaines après la
présidentielle où elle a acté dès le
début que emmanuel macron aurait une
majorité
c'était la carte de la vérité agathe
bref c'est ce qu'elle disait mais ce que
finalement c'est pas une stratégie
payante plutôt que de promettre
l'impossible entre guillemets de dire je
vais est élu premier ministre je sais
pas parce qu'on voit que jean luc
mélenchon en promettant l'impossible à a
créé un peu de rêve et d'envié une
dynamique auquel elle est la seule à
progresser oui
je sais pas si c'est grâce à sa
stratégie je trouve que c'est assez
incompréhensible sachant qu'elle a quand
même mené une bonne campagne des
présidentielles a obtenu un bon score
effectivement elle progresse aujourd'hui
leur assemblée nationale vous le disiez
pourrait avoir un parti pour la première
fois depuis 1986 alors qu'à l'époque
c'était grâce à la proportionnelle c'est
quand même énorme ce qu'elle a réalisé
et aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'elle
est en retrait qu'elle n'assume pas
cette progression qu'elle ne sait pas
comment l'utiliser il va il faudra voir
comment c'est là plus ou moins revenu
dans la campagne de l'entre-deux-tours
que oui alors on l'a vu elle est passée
de je voudrais 30 députés à 50 à
aujourd'hui elle a 10 ans mais il a
quand même fallu attendre l'entré deux
tours pour qu'elle ose prétendre à 100
députés c'était la deuxième femme de la
présidentielle c'est incompréhensible de
s'est passé à ce point c'était pas une
stratégie elle a loupé son et sa
composition négative alors si à la fin
afin d'avoir teo lt oryza chose mais en
fait elle a loupé jean luc mélenchon a
très bien joué en jouant la carte
premier ministre me sens forcément y
croire au maintien en mettant ça dans la
tête des français et dont est dans le
débat politique ma une bonne après s'est
rattrapé en effet rend suffisantes des
objectifs mais au début elle était
connue mais absente moi je pense que
c'est en partie en partie loupé mais en
partie elle a eu raison de ne pas
alimenter l'idée qu'on allait pouvoir
battre emmanuel macron parce que si on
peut battre emmanuel macron ce n'est pas
par le rassemblement national c'est à
dire que si elle avait alimenté la
machine on peut mettre emmanuel macron
en minorité à l'aurait pas été crédible
s'est passé à cette époque en profiter
c'est des recrues jean luc mélenchon
avait fait en moment des élections
européennes il avait dit on peut mettre
on peut battre emmanuel macron c'est
elle qui en a profité pas c'est elle qui
était en position de force la cie ont
été sortis de l'idc elle avait alimenté
elle même le discours on peut battre
emmanuel macron mais c'était la nièce
qui en profitaient donc elle n'a pas
voulu alimenter remplir le bas oui d'une
certaine manière faire le jeu de la
nuque donc elle est restée maison vaut
c'est juste il ya un autre point
intéressant c'est la façon dont
finalement la majorité des manuels
macron gère la question du quai du front
républicain par rapport au rassemblement
national on a vu que ça a flotté dès le
soir du premier tour très clairement
ensuite il ya eu des déclarations d
rétropédalage qui ont qui sont venus de
personnalités diverses notamment de
clément bonne mais également de la
première ministre mais vous regardez pas
grave y'a des circonscriptions il ya des
triangulaires et vous voyez par exemple
dans une triangulaire dans le sud-ouest
là aussi dans le lot-et-garonne
précisément où le candidat
de la majorité
refuse de se retirer parce que tout
simplement ils ne veulent pas appelé à
voter pour le candidat pour le candidat
de gauche donc ça veut dire que là aussi
il ya quand même ça traduit voyez cette
élection initiative est intéressante
parce qu'elle traduit aussi des tensions
qui existent au sein même de la majorité
par rapport à des questions de fond et
nous reste assez peu de temps j'aimerais
quand même qu'on parle de la droite qui
n' a plus que 87 candidats en lice pour
le second tour c'est déjà moins que le
nombre de députés de droite élu en 2017
mais pourrait peser davantage
politiquement on va voir dans un instant
comment j'aimerais tout d'abord qu'on se
penche sur la situation de la 4e
circonscription de paris et là on a la
députée maire brigitte kuster qui
affronte astrid panossian avec en jeu la
mobilisation des abstentionnistes
notamment c'est un reportage de
stéphanie de pierre avec marco pommier
cléa jouanno et thibaut castan
[Musique]
c'est presque un remake de 2017 au
premier tour la majorité est largement
en tête avec 41% des voix grâce à sa
candidate astrid pas notion mais pour
être élu dimanche 7 mars de la première
heure doit convaincre les
abstentionnistes et les indécis je viens
d'ouvrir des choses qui sont à la fois
qui pourrait relever à la fois du
catalogue de droite à la fois du
catalogue de gauche mais qui font ma
marque de fabrique parce que je pense
que c'est ce qui permet précisé nos
services cette promesse républicaine
vous avez fait votre choix vous
jusqu'au dernier jour jusqu'à la
dernière seconde
une candidate peut s'exprimer et se
traduit donc le dernier moment par cette
faille à bout se révéler astrid pas
notion espère bien être une des
révélations de ces législatives en
faisant tomber ce bastion de droite
tenus par brigitte kuster la députée les
républicains n'a fait que 28% des voix
au premier tour on a eu beaucoup de
pertes en ligne si je puis dire de
personnes qui sont pas venus voter
et puis un vote utile par rapport à la
peur de mélenchon et je pense que c'est
important que voilà la droite puisse
être présente au parlement une peur de
jean luc mélenchon sur laquelle la
candidate macro nist veut aussi
s'appuyer pour le second tour est-ce que
je reçois en tout cas et on verra les
résultats dimanche soir mais c'est une
inquiétude qui montrent très fortement
sur la dynamique de nu ps ça ça inquiète
beaucoup les habitants de cette
circonscription qui veulent donner au
présent macro ont les moyens d'agir pour
les cinq prochaines années en 2017 la
majorité présidentielle avait perdu au
second tour brigitte kuster avait
rattrapé son retard et gagné sur le fil
elle espère réitérer son exploit
alors
l'ancien maire du xviie est l'une des
deux dernières députés de droite à paris
plusieurs figures des républicains ont
donc fait le déplacement cette semaine
pour soutenir brigitte kuster ce qui
fera qu'on aura un groupe fort un groupe
indépendant à l'assemblée
très claire c'est non à mélenchon mais
on veut pas non plus du maquereau qu'on
a connu le cinq années précédentes qui
coûte rien qui tienne compte de rien et
qui décide tout seul al'inverse brigitte
kuster ne peut plus compter sur nicolas
sarkozy
mercredi l'ancien président a
discrètement rencontré à strip la notion
sa concurrente de la majorité
laurent de boissieu on sent l'inquiétude
de brigitte kuster devoir l'électorat de
droite allait voter pour les candidats
de la majorité ensemble par peur de jean
luc mélenchon une sorte de vote utile de
droite vers la majorité présidentielle
jouer mais une pompe partie lecture
droite est déjà parti le schéma ne
pensait que ceux qui restent sur les
derniers des mohicans et qu'ils voteront
jamais ce qu intéressante certains
reportages cessé de presser la pression
à la fin que le choix nicolas sarkozy ça
c'est bon on va en parler mais
effectivement il vient jouer les trouble
fête là dedans weeks rubrique l'austère
et une sarkozyste enfin elle était
plutôt il n'y apas alors que brigitte
kuster a été un soutien de la première
heure fidèle à nicolas sarkozy jusqu'au
bout y compris jusqu'en 2016 pendant la
primaire nicolas sarkozy aujourd'hui il
est il est ailleurs par rapport à sa
politique passée il a je rappelle entre
les deux tours la présidentielle il
avant le premier tour rien dit et ont
souhaité toile après il a appelé la fed
à droite à se rassembler derrière lui un
conte nicolas sarkozy très clairement
aujourd'hui il est plus il nous triste
war que l'histoire ça fait une politique
agathe sambre et à quoi joue nicolas
sarkozy
c'est intéressant se poser la question
en tout cas ce duel il symbolise deux
choses d'une part je pense la rupture
entre nicolas sarkozy et la droite
c'était une mesure qu'il a amorcée il ya
cinq ans et progressivement alors même
s'il ne s'est pas prononcé pour emmanuel
m'apprend avant le premier tour de la
présidentielle il y pensait déjà très
fort il n'a absolument rien fait pour
aider valérie pécresse donc rupture
d'une part entre nicolas sarkozy à
droite il fait même plus semblant il
soutient directement une candidate
ensemble et ensuite rupture au sein de
la droite elle-même entre ces deux
lignes ceux qui veulent se rapprocher
des manuels mariés et ceux qui veulent
rester à droite mais qui n'ont pas
trouvé la martingale et bien pour
exister pour se reconstruire or emmanuel
macron ans de benedetti sur cette ligne
tenu par christian jacob d'une
opposition déterminée mais utile qu'ils
pourraient voter au coup par coup les
réformes c'est c'est dangereux pour la
droite ya un risque d'implosion de la
droite c'est clair que s'il ya une
majorité relative et que cette majorité
relative est possible seulement avec
l'apport d'un groupe charnière imaginons
le groupe républicain on va revoir à
nouveau les divisions qui travaillent
finalement les républicains depuis cinq
ans réapparaître au grand jour entre
ceux qui diront oui on va filer un coup
de moins un coup de main à la majorité
et puis ceux qui sont sur une ligne
orthodoxe de défense de l'autonomie de
l'indépendance des républicains donc si
je voulais en effet ça remettra les
république est le paradoxe est que ça
remettra les républicains au centre du
jeu mais en même temps ça pourra les
fractures et où les diviser encore plus
et dans l'hypothèse inverse catherine
tricot cie emmanuel macron à sa majorité
absolue quel avenir pour la droite abbas
est ce que j'allais vous dire c'est que
je pense c'est quand même très compliqué
la droite en fait elle a toujours
historiquement réunis dans son sein de
façon inégale enfin une partie
bourgeoise une partie populaire la
partie bourgeoise maintenant elle est
incarnée très largement par par emmanuel
macron et son groupe avec les gens
d'horizons notamment et puis on voit
bien que le fasse à n'arrête pas quoi je
veux dire jean françois copé il est en
partance et mène nicolas sarkozy enfin
ils n'arrêtent pas de partir du côté ce
groupe bourgeois existent et sont
regroupe du côté des milieux macro il ya
la question d'une droite populaire que
xavier bertrand aurait pu incarner qu'il
n'a pas su incarner j'ai l'impression
que rachida dati c'est compliqué pour
elle parce que maire du 7e
arrondissement c'est quand même pas un
gage de très très populaire mais qu'elle
laissait d'eau de reprendre un petit peu
ça un combo ce flambeau je n'en vois pas
d'autre parce qu'en tout cas le goût
laurent vocale et ben oui mais si tu
avais vous dire alors légales le dernier
groupe c la droite vraiment vraiment
conservatrice et sa tête droite vraiment
conservatrice mais on l'a vu à plusieurs
reprises et notamment françois xavier
bellamy il a fait 6 % à l'élection
européenne et donc ça ne fait plus rien
en france cette droite
ultraconservatrice très vite est ce que
je vais dire c'est qu'en gros sur le
plan économique bel air a été siphonné
illogiquement papara parle le sont par
les mac os nist sauf il y avait que sur
la question de conserver du
conservatisme où il y avait une droite
conservatrice qui se retrouvaient pas là
dessus sur émail mâcon mais l'affairé
s'est pas ce qui permet de faire
majorité en france aujourd'hui il nous
reste très peu de temps j'aimerais juste
qu'on évoque cette hypothèse d'une
majorité relative en faveur des manuels
macron ça s'est posé sous michel rocard
2,88 à 91 à l'époque il a utilisé 28
fois de 49,3 on peut plus gouverner
comme ça aujourd'hui la réforme de la
constitution l'empêchent est ce que ce
serait viable sur la durée une majorité
relative aux est ce qu on s'orienterait
vers une 10e d'une dissolution de
l'assemblée assez rapides ont fait un
tour de table rapide comme une majorité
relative est toujours possible c'est
toujours viables sa fabriquera au fur et
à mesure des textes des majorités de
compromis ensuite tout dépend quelle est
cette majorité relative c'est une
majorité relative à l'intérieur de la
majorité macro nist c'est une chose
c'est une majorité relative encore une
fois qui a besoin pour est relatif
d'aller chercher d'autres groupes ça
sera bien évidemment beaucoup plus
compliqué en raison notamment de ce que
vous venez de dire c'est à dire que le
40 h 30 il ya plus il ya plus un droit
de tirage est limité laurent de boissieu
aussi peut-être rapide soit c'est
vraiment le même relative à quelques
voix près de la manche et absolue dans
ce cas il y aura des duels sur la droite
voire sur les un peu sur la gauche soit
soit c'est très éloigné avait rejeté
absolue dans ce cas là est ce que les
républicains arrive à peser sur une
alliance gouvernement en pesant sur la
ligne et trois possibilités notamment il
ya des lipides et autres maires qui
pincent potentiellement élus qui
préfèrent un groupe d'outre-mer et
régionaliste avec la tutelle que des
analystes pour être une force d'appoint
ce après une force d'appoint qui
négocient charme en surplomb de
de leur territoire un soutien ponctuel
sagat lambret je pense que c'est un
cauchemar pour emmanuel macron il les
dit plusieurs fois il ne voulait pas
gérer dans son second mandat et c'est
pour ça que pour lui l'enjeu primordial
c'était d'avoir une majorité absolue
pour avoir les mains libres pour
présider et mettre en place ces réformes
est aujourd'hui s'il ne l'avait pas eh
bien ce serait très compliqué il serait
effectivement obligé de composer tantôt
sur sa droite tantôt sur sa gauche il
n'aime pas trop composé par ailleurs ce
qu'ils voulaient à tout prix éviter on
raconte aussi dans le livre avec alou
zelter c'était que edouard philippe et
son parti horizon est trop de pouvoir et
au gel à décines c'est que harper
d'avoir pourrait aussi avoir ce rôle
pivot très vite catherine frécaut moi je
donne poussée de la gauche ça pourrait
aboutir une droitisation des manuels
macro paradoxalement oui ça c'est
évident que il serait chars de tenter
d'aller chercher le renfort du côté la
droite mais moi ce que je pense qu'il
sera compliqué c'est qu'il n'a pas de
majorité politique dans ce pays ça veut
dire qu'à pas que le poids à l'intérieur
de l'assemblée nationale il ya aussi la
réalité profonde du pays et pour
l'instant il n'a pas de majorité
politique et n'a pas fait campagne et il
n'a pas un bon résultat au premier tour
des législatives
merci beaucoup c'est la fin de cette
émission je rappelle que le vivent donc
que vous ne publiez l'étrange victoire
macron de l'histoire secrète aux édition
de l'observatoire je vous rappelle
seront des bois ne pas manquer dimanche
soir soirée électorale sur lcp avec
brigitte boucher et myriam ankawa tout
de suite c'est valérie brochard édition
inédite de z zone d'education
documentaire avec la diffusion du
documentaire infiltré à auch fixe suivie
d'un débat entre la réalisatrice et des
élèves du lycée henri iv à paris très
belle soirée à tous et bon week-end sur
lcp
[Musique]